big news out of The Simpsons did you
know that the Simpsons is still on the
air The Simpsons the cartoon that
started in 1989 I believe has been on
for 34
seasons and there have been many
cultural memes that have come out of The
Simpsons one of which is Homer Simpson
strangling his son Bart but
apparently no
longer that's quite a grip see March
strangling the boy is paid off just
kidding I don't do that anymore times
have
changed so it's a little joke about this
meme from The Simpsons but it's actually
The Simpsons telling you something real
about the show and about how the
political correctness has affected the
show Homer doesn't strangle Bart anymore
used to be whenever Bart would do
something bad or would go strangle him
Bart's like ah but now they don't do
that we no longer joke about strangling
our kids in society now back 30 years
ago when The Simpsons had or 20 years
ago or 15 years ago when Homer would
strangle Bart it's not that it was a
culturally accepted to strangle your
children it was a joke it was a joke
about how sometimes your kids get on
your nerves and you just want to ring
their little necks you know but you're
not you don't actually want to do it you
love your kids we're not allowed to even
joke about that
anymore however now we are allowed to uh
castrate our children now we are allowed
to kill our children through abortion 30
years ago in polite company one would
not really defend abortion 30 years ago
when the simpons was starting out making
jokes about strangling their kids even
if you supported abortion you you would
probably say look abortion is obviously
an evil thing nobody wants abortions we
all want fewer abortions but because of
of the difficulty and complexity of this
issue abortion ought to be safe legal
and rare that was the Democrat position
it should be rare because of how awful
it is but you know we should tolerate it
that that was the whole debate now
however we're at a stage where people
will say we need to shout our abortions
oh abortions are so wonderful we need to
enshrine in the Ohio state constitution
a right to kill babies up until the
moment of birth oh a baby's not even a
baby no it's just a clump of cells it's
a product of pregnancy it's not no it's
good it's an affirmative good shout your
abortion I I think there might be a
relationship here
as Society gets more finicky as Society
gets a little more precious about the
things we're allowed to joke about we
seem to become more baric in the things
that we're allowed to
do maybe that's why we can't joke about
it anymore it's too
real the fact that
we with with the affirmation of our
society all the way up to and including
the president of the United States now
celebrate castrating our children
mutilating our children reducing our
children's life expectancy killing our
children even now that we actually do
that may maybe maybe it's that the jokes
are too real maybe we don't we don't cut
out the jokes because we've come a a
Kindler gentler Society maybe we cut out
the jokes for precisely the opposite
reason right now go to Pur talk.com
today is Veterans Day our friends over
at P talk have been working toward
alleviating $10 million in veteran debt
thanks to your support they are over 90%
to that goal today think about this the
US military is made up of 100%
volunteers these are men and women who
willingly sacrifice everything they have
for this country when they are done
serving they return home to a tight job
market and outrageous living expenses
that is why I am so happy that a private
company like Pur talk has jumped into
help when you switch to P Talk's
Lightning Fast 5G Network they will
donate a portion of every new order to
this noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell phone service P talks plan started
just 20 bucks a month offering unlimited
talk text more data and a mobile hotspot
just go to P talk.com kwes to make the
switch let's rally together let's show
our unwavering support for our veterans
visit Pur talk.com kwes switch to PE
talk today it's the right move it is the
American way Pur
talk.com right now go to hillsdale.edu
are you a few years or decades out of
school and wondering what did I learn
what was the point you might even be
thinking I don't have the time to learn
something new if that's you you're not
alone it's not too late Hillsdale
College is offering more than 40 free
online courses learn about the works of
CS Lewis the rise and fall of the Roman
Republic or the history of the ancient
Christian church with Hillsdale colleges
online courses if you are not sure where
to start check out CS Lewis on
Christianity in this seven lecture
course you will examine some of Lewis's
classic Works including Mere
Christianity the screw tape letters and
the abolition of man you'll also see
what Lewis had to say about scripture
prayer suffering Joy Heaven and Hell the
course is self-paced so that you can
start whenever and wherever and roll now
in CS Lewis on Christianity to discover
Lewis's core lessons on Christianity and
how to apply Faith to your life go to
hillsdale.edu
canw to enroll there's no cost it's easy
to get started hillsdale.edu NS
hillsdale.edu
slns Hey Dirty Mike Bryson was taken
here and I regret to inform you that my
name is still taken
I need you to put on your Nostradamus
cap for my question let's say the
betting odds are correct and Trump is
the nominee given that Ronda Santos
cannot run for governor again what do
you think his political future looks
like I can't imagine he plans to go
gently into that good night after his
term is over given that Florida is
already quite red in DC I can't see him
running for house or Senate does he fall
in line behind Trump after dropping out
and hope for a cabinet position should
Trump win I do think Trump's DieHard
supporters will soften on him similarly
to Cruz after after the 2016 election do
you think there's an Avenue for him to
capture the Republican Party in the
future what's the pathway for that
anyway thanks for answering my question
love the show yes I think there is a
future for Ronda santz I don't think
that people hate Ronda santis I think
there are a lot of people like me who
really like Donald Trump and really like
Ronda santz I I think I know that that's
not represented in the med all that I
might be the only person with the show
who's saying that but I think that's a
lot of people and they'll say either oh
I really like Trump but I'm I'm rooting
for disantis now or they'll say look I
like Trump Trump's the man he's running
he he can get these things done and Ron
is good too but he needs a little time
to cook and he'll he'll have his turn
also and I think uh you know if if uh
the relationship between Trump and Cruz
could be rehabilitated I think the
relationship between Trump and DeSantis
could too I don't think it's personal
with
DeSantis you you know it's like that
line uh from The
Godfather when when uh Michael Corone
says he wants to go shoot the cop that
beat him up and Tom Hagen and sunny the
brother they're laughing at him they say
oh you're getting all riled up he says
it's not it's not personal it's not
personal sunny it's only business it's
only business sunny I think that's the
same thing here with with Trump and Dan
santis I think it's business and then it
could move on uh I could see Dan santis
maybe running for US Senate maybe I
could see him going into Private
Industry for a little while and coming
back and running again later though that
would be a little bit
tougher but look he's a bulldog and he's
very good and his views represent more
the future of the Republican party than
do the views of the squishes in the libs
so I think he's got a pretty pretty
bright future even though he's taking on
Trump man what a clip that was now hey
hey hey ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles YouTube channel we'll see
you next time